what she said is I have my personal
views and I would vote according to
those views but if the law is the law
then I will respect the law yeah and I
would not wish to tell other people how
to behave for example I myself would not
have children outside of marriage but we
live in a society where other people are
allowed to do that and it's a [__]
disgrace Forbes 32 was not a member of
the Scottish Parliament when the law was
passed in early 2014 but has said that
she would have voted nor if she had been
she's a member of the Free Church of
Scotland the Free Church of school it's
all about freedom of those they [__]
love a bit of Freedom unless you say the
wrong thing in your house in which case
they'll lock you up in other broadcast
interviews she gave her views on
abortion children being born outside
marriage and Trust [__] me she just went
anyway
she's very softly spoken you know really
yeah she has to be with [__] views
like that man uh Forbes talk times radio
that she would seek forgiveness uh for
any pain or her that she had caused this
is where she's starting to lose me to be
honest and it's getting into dangerous
territory the reason I wanted to talk
about this Francis Anton hide this for a
sec is basically what she said is I have
my personal views and I would vote
according to those views yeah but if the
law is the law then I will respect the
law yeah and I would not wish to tell
other people how to behave for example I
myself would not have children outside
of marriage but we live in a society
where other people are allowed to do
that and it's a [__] disgrace she
didn't have that part but she definitely
thought it yeah she did but my point is
this is actually very important yeah
right because people should be able to
have private opinions about how one
ought to behave
and as long as they're not seeking to
enforce those opinions on other people
we should be able to respect that
do you see what I mean no but what about
Twitter
or about Twitter well that's where you
go and put all your private opinions and
make them public right that's what you
do but I just think we've forgotten this
this simple idea that people can have an
opinion that isn't necessarily going to
be followed through with others for
example
I I mean I can Envision circumstances in
which my wife and I like in in you know
like very severely disabled fetuses or
whatever like things like that right
that we might have an abortion but other
than that I personally would never want
to do that right and I don't think he
would either no right that does not
necessarily mean that we would want to
Outlaw it yeah right indeed so that is
an example of that like I for example
I'm just glad I don't have to legislate
on the issue of abortion but I don't
legislate on any issue but it should be
a man who does it
you sure you want to play with this one
man yeah you sure
yeah
do you know what I mean though yeah of
course I know what you mean yeah of
course I know look the reality is as
well
if you have if you start going down this
road then what's going to happen is
you're going to preclude religious
people from entering High office
that is a good idea right yeah exactly
Mike let's do it let's [__] do it
but I agree with you I think a
politician should be allowed to have uh
private views about their religion and
they are more than entitled to them and
the reality is look if you've got
someone coming out and saying they're a
Christian which which every prime
minister does they should be thrown to
the lines exactly
exactly
how Christian are you there yeah now
you've got a line about to chew your
bollocks off
are you a Christian thought not no but
otherwise when you know you
I don't know mate
you're right people should be able to be
religious and have their religious
opinion without without being canceled
for it yeah but these people come out
and then say I'm Christian so I let you
know there's a lot of look political
leaders who are purported to be
Christians whether they are whether
aren't I don't know but that is the
thing well if you do if you are a
Christian you don't believe in gay
marriage sorry
because it's not natural is it exactly
Adam and Eve no adamant Steve
imagine if Cape Forbes came out and said
that yeah that would be great I may not
[__] knock my head off I'd vote for
you know just for the troll Factor
so that's the thing uh music cast in the
chairs discovered sarcasm mate really
well geez guys stop being so mean
very funny joke well done fantastic high
level of skill there yeah
next
foreign